hi Madison hello Bob you rock welcome to
drunk I don't even think he meant to do
that one I don't think he did either
it's just out of sticks and I really
wanted success all right so welcome back
to drunk minecraft I'm still playing on
my mini keyboard yeah yours quick poll
was that the funniest [ __ ] that's ever
happened to mark hi hi no probably
probably not guys entertained it all in
last episode no I was entertained so I
don't I'm sure you would tell us how not
entertain you were when you see it oh
god why is there so much water I don't
ask you see from the explosion that
happened years ago you're building a
sandcastle wait I wasn't building
anything actually a shame yes I tracked
a sheep in sand Oh way to go I was bored
well good work where are my manners
unreal right now right now I'm
harvesting wood mark so oh you're okay
all right well I can't even eat bread
for some stranger's I just got my stuff
back Jessica yeah yeah yeah I can't eat
you don't have to yell when you type
dude why not I need to shout it like
keyboard is so tiny I just need to yell
at them yes letters lots of sticks right
wait
god dammit wakes in the shape of a
ladder what sticks why would dicks be in
the shape of a ladder
god damn it Bob come on you said
outlined off dicks for one second and
get in the game I didn't do nothing I
don't remember how to make home stapling
a ladder
yes exactly later either what's
happening I don't need I don't know you
just have to be really persistent with
the eating mark ah that's me ya know in
what way that could possibly describe
you but okay God you know you know you
know I'm talking about when you eat
stuff you're just like man okay eat this
whole thing
perfect
I determined that look good I don't even
know anyway you got 40 I've got 48
ladders that enough that's enough get up
here and get some cobblestone and start
building why are the [ __ ] did you get
four more ladders
I'm up you're not look up you douche you
got my cup control it in is so tiny
right now ah I couldn't see you for your
tiny kiss on my hands when I'm trying to
play oh my god why is it just why is it
so small it's not small don't call it
small now your hand like people the
keyboard I don't know cuz it's a mini
keyboard it's the kid the keyboard is
definitely small my brother has like 10
keywords and so I thank him for saving
nah this whole recording session cuz
otherwise we would be I'd be out running
trying to get a new keyboard from Meijer
there got a ladder thank you here now
start building is all right here what
builds a building do you not see what
you're standing on I see it but how you
are we gonna use the ladder if you're
filling it all in we'll put it on the
side we have weight I just built a
ladder entrance oh no it's not right I
don't have any stone on my building oh
my god wait wait yeah wait seriously
wait I'm gonna I'm gonna chop your head
off
wait on a spike and then smash you to
pieces with my tiny Beauty keyboard I'm
gonna pour beer on you really speaking
with your drinking oh we have I still
have a little bit of drink left I
haven't made another one cuz it kind of
fire I'm drinking Michelob Ultra no this
is all a mess it sounds that's not new
youngling politely I mix funny Jack and
Pat Morgan's it's not good
hey how do I get down from here without
eyeing jump you can survive yeah I'm
gonna go jump into the water do that you
do that wait give me the ladder to have
any ladder left yeah I've got 26 how
much ladder do you have
how many letters were worse job on him
down shut I wasn't making fun of you I
was just hanging a throw down Bob there
then Bob bit down there anyway I got
everyone out there we're making a mob
forum I've already tested this design it
works it does it unless they escape then
it doesn't more than that is Bad News
Bears oh then I die
Hey okay I die too
I really hope you die wait actually I
didn't die so what do you hope I die who
had their hopes Wade dies yeah put the
hands down look at all those hands up
Mike job oh-ho-ho they're so me Oh God
weights up I wish I wasn't being
recorded actually was i stupid true that
he finally admits it ha ha ha ha fine
little weight loss out here that ham
chip
yeah Rick other win a long time for you
to file all right none ah oh [ __ ] oh yes
what I died why are you alive I see you
ah yeah I'm alive with none of the
things I was previously holding where'd
you diet where all my [ __ ] is and don't
take it cuz I need it no you don't need
before I landed in the water oh that's
our exit point that's how we get off of
this thing
ok I found a bunch of stuff down here
wait I'm gonna kill you I'm gonna take
it so you murder your face ruin out
there this is why we hate Wade
I didn't do anything was you ruin
everything yes exactly
you ruined my keyboard you ruined I said
you ruined the webcams like seriously
Wade what's okay what you guys saw it
marks built his own drink on his own
keyboard I'm pretty it wasn't a plethora
of them in his house that's not how I
remember it
yeah pretty sure video evidence will
show that Wade snuck into my room and
Dawn I really hope I really hope you
like Photoshop in somehow
gallon of water noe that would be pretty
epic oh gosh oh did you die goddamn leg
no it's just laggy I keep falling off
goddamn leg [ __ ] goddamn laughs
where's this ladder insurance you
supposedly built on the side you douche
that's the one I built he said he built
a new one oh this I haven't built the
ladder yet idiot why so many ladder
interest is Wade jeez it's one I don't
isn't one Greece said he was you said
you were destroying this one I don't
know but he said huh Bob I don't think
that why do we need another ladder
injuries I don't recall we ever did Bob
wanted my ladders to build his ladder
entry I made one it's over here
you better not be talk about the one I
made is it oh where oh okay when I
wouldn't laughter Bob I would have left
if you were in ways interest oh man I'm
short son of oh there's so much freakin
lag okay anyway so this all feeds into
this central hole here no these are you
built the latter one over you it I am
aware oh my god remember how in the last
episode I was happy because nothing bad
happened to Bob oh god oh this is the
best is not quiet worse and we're just
this one favorite way who built this
Robert this is built wrong what wrong oh
I put that there no one's put any
cobblestone down but you know hang on
shut up Wade I put that one cobblestone
down so I could apparently kill myself
good oh I need more cobblestone I got
some guinea I gotta go gotta go make
some salt one more letter hang on oh god
I can't type it's so full
zombie I need so much cobble here like
so so much Yolo Yolo Yolo what yeah the
cert work no yes I don't know here don't
look behind you then
marble Yolo boyo what the hell are you
guys oh you know Yolo shut up you know
cobble Yolo you know I need so much mmm
gobbles what I'm imagining is gonna rain
like brakes from the sky and crush us
that's gross oh my god it's raining from
the sky what Dell Wade really really
Wade really I asked you if dirt work
that you said yes if you're such a dick
oh my god really
did you not say yes does this look good
to you get the hell out here with your
frigging dirt guy see everybody out
there really would you build a dirt
piece POS right here in the middle of
all this cobble when the couple wasn't
here ah whoa house clubs oh god I wish
you died Bob where are you please give
me some sanity - oh yeah also ladder
I need Johnny letter okay we don't need
more letter I can't even pick this up
I can't nee equaling pick this up can't
high on this keyboard it's good I can
barely get away wait you're stealing
away
oh I'm still in the way can't can't
can't even pick it up too much
bah bah Oh God ready full Oh what are
you doing wait really
[ __ ] you oh you guy Oh God
Jude you go how are you dial the word is
the word mobster
Hey look I don't even know don't hit the
same pattern all the way around yep yep
yep yep yep I'm gonna help okey-dokey me
too okay wait go die in a fire
yeah that thing right there
mean no it's not this is supposed to be
here wait you suck you're so stupid we
just asked it was the same pan yeah you
didn't look at the pattern now did ya no
I didn't you did you didn't look at the
pattern yeah I hate you so much
hey oh no I wasn't recording the entire
time
watch kidding me totally joking with you
but yeah would I go on recording watch
yeah sorry
what he's lying yeah I'm lying okay yeah
I'm like mark you're the worst huh
aiya yeah mark Morgan enable rescue
again oh all marks faulted the last
episode was a failure all was not with
wait everyone saw Wade came in my room
and spilled drink all over back all over
to my house wall sitting here on camera
I ran over he's just that good folks
he's just that good
hey that's kondal you think God did it
but I didn't shut up Wade I mean Rick
all right [ __ ] Wade so we got this here
you see how great this is now bill did I
don't I don't understand build it up
Adam more got build up one more that we
need water so get iron buckets and fill
them up with water we need lots of water
I saw your zombie we need buckets of
water build up everything one more yeah
just the outside be inside to all those
flow though all those points need to be
built up one more but not the low points
yeah not the low points okay
this yah and then the ceiling needs to
be too high for it to work correctly
oh it's cutie oh we need more ceiling
who put that put that chest there that's
Domino it's got cobble in it okay that's
I write it good girl
Oh what are you speaking Zulu though
everything up one block except for the
lowest floor yeah except no no no about
the in-betweens
no seriously mark I think he's doing it
right what the hell well I asked if
these did not beat a wrong way oh my god
damn it I told you God I just asked if
it was a li the lowest floor wait what
do you just ask that when you ask this
[ __ ]
how was it listening to you dammit I
asked the guy who's made this before
gah wait I swear ok no the outside ring
built up one more and then we need happy
in slabs idiot idiot I know I know I
know Bob this is what I deal with on a
daily basis daily daily basis hey Mark
you missed a spot
shut up his leg all right so I'm facing
the little jump jump around we why
should your own slabs now Yolo burger
hey get out of here Chuck jump dude I
can't build on him that's Latin
ah hello that's Latin that's lat
Oh yep that's not why she jumped up cuz
that's what she be it's not jelly cobble
ding table Oh
lazy oh I don't know would wear my was
so lazy
unbelievably lazy what is this crap you
don't laughs yeah I'm too full of
cobblestone to pick up at a stone slab
well drop them drive to home but there's
cobblestone everywhere I have to hold
your hand through everything okay now I
got it I got enough for all of them
group no maybe not blue live some blue I
have loop nine bloop bloop bloop bloop
ah damn it put in fill this up hey I
mean fail alright damn tiny keyboard I
can't do anything right
bloop bloop bark talents not tall enough
no oh yeah wait no I put this down here
all about to say yeah Oh Nikes oh-de-boy
boos we're leaving this chest here I
gotta hope not ah what do you hope not
that doesn't even make sense we need
water
where's all our water I can't I didn't
ah ha not in here okay it's in this uh
oh he gave us water it's in this chest
I gotta get Han don't you guys don't
place water because you don't know where
to place it
I'm so placing what I do not place water
I'm gonna get that ho and say some
inappropriate things ah you don't know
what I said though eh I do you do when
did I tell you what I yeah nobody knows
what I said even Wade doesn't know what
I said that's it actually he's stupid I
don't add it up yeah yeah yeah are we
talking about what are we talking about
fill this ceiling in huh uh-oh the topic
or doesn't matter but yeah it needs to
be filled in up top with cobblestone um
yes that'll be fine there should we go
one higher than fill in all the way uh
maybe dude do whatever feels right
mark that's not how this works huh oh no
whatever we do you're gonna be pissed it
needs to be in two spaces is them is the
minimum for what we go like this mark
though we do need to go one higher look
behind you mark like this I like that
yeah Wade's got it surprisingly Wade has
it correct Oh John yeah it's amazing
what happens when you actually tell me
the right answer let's see more uh more
water plox I'm still leak I just spit on
my keyboard yeah it's okay for now ah
thank you
that's lava that is not water yep dip
dip deep oh I can stop it what why don't
know mob spawner because we need to get
I'm in an hour wait asks the correct
question we don't even have a house shut
why didn't you build a house whose
because I was dead
I'm pretty sure that was your job boy
yeah that's it I know but while I was
getting my prize the ladders while I was
getting my keyboard you were supposed to
be building a house that's why you see I
got a ladder why why who put the ceiling
there who did that who did that who
screwed up what where the ceiling that's
above us who put that there
none of us the one where you said hey
that's right yeah who did that howdy
ha ha ha I knew it all right we need
vines go get vines fine lines and uh
stone buttons we need stone what the
[ __ ] why can't you say this while we're
down there
get it get it do my bidding my minion
just punched you one more oh no oh no oh
my god oh no no no no your bowline how
I'm dead oh come on
well there is a guest come on buddy
where the ladders not going oh look did
okay Bob it's missing you Amy
dammit dammit dammit dammit dammit
oh oh [ __ ] it
is the worst that's the worst you did
this
you think I did but I didn't you might
kick it out of the water
dawn cares uh okay thank okay oh my god
Cabo just exploded all over my not all
over me but blue spruce I need vines oh
no he'd vines well I just lightens both
of those things please
oh my god my mind of care crash your
mind of care a car hire car
you're my name it's all in the middle
that does not help me the body is just
going down that's not good
why do I have a diamond he'll behave
Martius go get this is the one I died I
was given a diamond helmet consolation
okay alright final phase is initiated
Jenna no no no no Jenna gonna Nana gonna
depend on a nun good uninhibited yay
water bought this ladders not finished
do you know I'm working on it anymore we
got it we got it it's all taken care of
waves you go build the freaking house
like you were supposed to do a long time
ago all of my stuff is in your flippin
hole one cares
all right just get out of here get out
of here no not you Bob I'm tell you to
wait of course I'm tired I'm not there
just get out of here no one owes your
anyway I hate you so much I hate you
some waving at you right thank you do
but oh no you probably do ha ha ha you
thinks you hate me but you do I just
gave you the finger online really oh
come on oh you're repeating Oh
I they say what's finger whoa boss whoa
guess what finger you'd probably expect
yeah I Drive yeah he probably is right
why who would get is that wrong
okay now index finger left index finger
oh good golly missed everybody shut no
one's talking you shut up
no sorry that's delivery you shut up you
think you shut me up but I'm ask you
some what you think you shut up but mask
you stop Matt he's the man Matt mask
mask yeah ma'am a threesome all right
now now we get to play the game of where
the [ __ ] is the letter it's over here
here it is
oh god why does it go all the way down
what why doesn't it do that oh it does
it's - it's just weird that scared me
all right now Oh God do you take my
stone blocks out of my chest with that
would not be what this is you're such a
[ __ ] oh god I love thank you for not
stealing all my [ __ ] mark oh you're
welcome I tried to avoid it
see I'm nice wayde's just dick well yeah
this was his weight you're such a [ __ ]
that sounds about right hey
a bunch of [ __ ] flowed out from the
bottom so can someone come me at this is
like now stacks and stacks of dude crap
okay well hey look it's all my stuff
including my death certificate
alright now we just wait for the mobs to
roll in it's gonna be really
underwhelming it's Netmark why aren't
the mobs rolling in we have to be up
there to get them to roll in I don't
know no we don't this this without the
mob spawners it should work normally
where I'm a big baby okay no zoo zombies
yes what are you tired okay give me the
Dombey it's over here all [ __ ] I get you
to work then we'll be golden I want that
diamond helmet so much which diamond
he'll never it's never gonna happen
oh that went in there oh yeah behind all
the cobble all right let's see who gets
it first stone sword cobblestone
cobblestone cobblestone cobblestone
cobblestone cobblestone howls town owl
sound cobblestone diamond helmet now ah
wait wait
no the first item I get is a death
certificate I'm done haha I hate I hate
this uh yeah
check me out check me out check me out
check me out
thank you Oh Oh check me out
oh no I turn sticky he's on Oh to that I
need to make Crouch not shift for that
to work
what I don't know of anyone that uses
sticky key so you like turn that option
off what's the point of that I don't
even know what that I don't know are
there I do it to hit shift three times
isn't it five ah that like if you have
like it I don't know
disease or something where you can't
move your hands very fast
what if you're really old my mom farm
doesn't not work again my mommy's home
spawner doesn't not work again so what I
said my mob farm does not work again me
big shine
he did say me big said I said oh ah why
do you work mark why do you suck so much
at this shut up I got this ha ha
zombie will fix it he said that doesn't
make you good at this
he said he why we'll fix it I did it
correctly he's gonna like it I'm on a
record yeah it's just that on this
server like mob spawns are a little
wonky because it's like you know it's
you know you know hey Mark wait wait
marks and still there's something on the
back of your armor what come over by a
torch and what looking hi hi hi know
also that what I trust you I don't trust
Wade if waited said that I would have
picked up Amelia but you wait house
house coming um I need coal get coal you
douche uh
oh no we have to play where the [ __ ] is
the letter oh it's not there
oh no whoa I didn't die nice hey hey way
do you want to see something funny yeah
I can't believe you fell for that I
thought you're gonna do something about
Rick really that was pretty funny don't
you think hilarious
I enjoyed it very much oh we got three
minutes left ami listen I hear spawn
smart zombie what I do I do hear them
really Oh whoo I hear em - oh hello yes
it works
yeah it works and what does this
accomplish it gives us moths to
facilitate the ease of killing this this
Oh
so with that we get levels and enchant
our hey Wade you want to see something
funny yeah I swear if you're right
behind guess where I are we had spawns
but oh you dick no yeah why me ha ha ha
ha ha get out of here
Wow Wade you're not good at this I had
one heart left you know you're really
about it hey Mark you want to see
something funny
no I do not oh don't hate me I can't
take you you've got way too much iron
[ __ ] I got an enchanted gourd
you're such a dick I'm not gonna kill
you but if the bar goes either I'm gonna
die ha ha ha ha
alright ok even even even I never killed
you ok sorry I killed Wade who you hate
oh yeah did you oh that's right I'm so
sorry Bob oh so sorry
you want my debt bow to kill Wade with I
don't have any arrows yeah I got it
really take that take that bow hang on I
need to pick my stuff up before I got
the boat you dick you dick ha ha ha
don't don't give her any arrows I get
it-- I got arrows ooh ha ha ha ha
God why don't you hit me from over there
a [ __ ] lag come here come here
oh ha ha ha ha good you know you're
gonna get ya oh man I lost my boots
somehow I don't get you I don't make
sense
Sita where you going buddy wait where
your buddy once as far away as possible
come here Rick I just want hot dude we
couldn't get along for too long you know
that we are going oh yeah no yes now I
have to get my [ __ ] through all your
[ __ ] to get my I'm not the right ball
either my boat my bow is enchanted in
all that
god damn it oh wait would I melt you the
way Oh where's my damn enchanted bow you
dick
you never gave you I gave you an
enchanted freaking block going on there
it is wear it now I got my arrows okay
we're actually on time we're out of time
I've got nothing we're out of time you
dicks ha ha ha all right we actually
accomplished something for the first
time ever in drunk minecraft and we
built a mob form I'm I built the castle
of the sky one no you did not oh I wish
I that way to help with that
I remember that you're trying to kill me
okay all right we're all I had time so
thank you all so much for watching as
always you'll see you in the next video
bye bye right away my high